Islam is free from this this has nothing
to do with Islam I want to make that
clear
hijab is
okay
Islam that is establishing a Masjid and
a community center if you donate to
build this Masjid Allah build a house
for you in Jannah with bricks of gold
and silver every person who prays in
this Masjid every child that memorized
the Quran you will inshallah share in
that reward donate now guys and do not
delay sister what's your name
foreign
okay firstly firstly let's talk about
what's important is our life which was
which was taken yes it was the life of
this yeah I mean and many more okay
let's talk about that I think that's
really important
um the the thing I'm just a little bit
confused about before I come to this it
was her name was
okay okay so firstly we acknowledge that
I'm a Muslim by the way I came to Islam
10 years ago my family is um my dad's
atheist agnostic just to give you an
idea I was born Muslim but I'm not
Muslim anymore okay so so I came to
Islam okay I came to Islam you left this
stuff okay I need to know your religion
I I equally respect everyone regardless
of their religion okay you don't need to
explain anything to me okay get your get
to the point okay so if I can just get
to the point please yeah so the point is
number one that she was killed
um what I saw by the way I don't know
much if you can educate me I'll be happy
why so yeah
yeah
you don't have enough information that's
correct information that's why I came to
you that's why I came to you
that's why I came here
we believe that he's using Islam as a
tool to kill people okay we don't care
that what religion people have look at
people in Iran can have many religions
whatever that they like they can be
Christians they can be Muslims they can
choose whatever that they like but
imposing and using a tool using religion
as a tool and forcing it on people and
killing people in the name of it that is
wrong that is so wrong that we don't
need even to talk about it this girl was
with her brother okay okay
was wearing something that I believe and
many people believed that was absolutely
normal okay she wasn't without a scarf
she was having a normal but she was kept
by the forest a police and then morality
separated them separated with her
brothers
so her brother was separated from the
sister yes
and then murdered the sister okay so how
do you think that brother is feeling now
just imagine you obviously if that was
my sister yes yes
going to another city imagine that you
just go to another city and then they
keep your sister and then after a few
hours they give you someone that is
gonna die in the hospital three days
later just imagine how her brother is
feeling now it feels my sister if it was
my sister I'll be very angry I'll do
more than that why don't you just have
your opinion I hear from my Muslim
Brothers is based on their assumption
and interpretation of Islam but in Iran
Islam is a political brand for the
totalia
is their political brand yes to brutally
suppress any other thoughts and any
other movement in that society when they
put this tag as an Islamic State or
Islamic country on Iran it doesn't
reflect true nature of the society it's
their brand okay and they're imposing it
on everyone no matter what they think
that's that's what that that's why
people are now on this tree uh fighting
protesters protesting and fighting for
Freedom okay because they aren't happy
with these totalitarian system okay so
you know I saw a video please educate me
I'm here to be educated um where she is
in is that in hospital or police custody
when she falls and she where did that
happen I don't know it is
Sue collapses yes yes because that way
she dies yeah because before that they
cracked Harris car open so before that
she was she had a um a tractor she took
her in custody okay and brutally beat
her up okay
then later on in the police station yeah
because of the injury Hemorrhage in her
in her uh brain she collapses and passes
away okay and they don't tell you the
entire story but whatever they tell you
has who puts a lot of focus on that
footage only okay okay it was because of
natural causes but that's yeah that's
what they were saying listen to her
father listen to her brother they are
very brave and they're talking and they
are so many questions but why the
government is not answering those
questions if you want to actually feel
the brothers if you have a sister she's
wearing her job imagine in here
yeah
you know beat her up because she has a
job it's the same feeling yeah it's not
right okay so as as I've listened to you
guys like I didn't know some stuff I
really appreciate thank you for
clarifying for me as a Muslim man
um what's that number one against the
whole regime of Iran period like as
Muslim Muslims were against that anyways
and number two in Islam actually to take
a life like there is no prescribed
punishment for someone not wearing hijab
there is no prescribed that prescribed
punishment for adultery for dinner for
slander for robbery
um for um apostasy things but when it
comes to the hijab there is it doesn't
mean it's not a sin but there is nothing
that says that you you can kill somebody
over hijab this is a big fat lie which
is a different trouble I'm just
clarifying here
people for a variety exactly exactly
this is an excuse me
exactly yes they have their brutal
police force yes yes to try and silence
people yes
our politicians our government yes yes
we're not against anything other than
that and yes young people if yeah if
someone would force or kill any woman in
Iran yes for wearing a job yes I would
do the same thing yes
you know you know sometimes you know
like in France for example yeah
exactly It's just sometimes you know
what it is we understand where you're
coming from somebody's lost their life
at the end of the day like like Allah
says in the Quran if you take one so
listen to kill the whole of humanity and
if you save one Soul so what we want to
tell you guys I know some of you guys
are not Muslim but the thing is Islam is
free from this this has nothing to do
with Islam I want to make that clear I
want to make that clear you know you
know the behavior of these regimes yes
is damaging the society yes you know who
takes the damage even more than that
Islam yes exactly in the name of Islam
same as Isis they do it I have to go and
say me I'm sorry I'm not Isis I have to
clarify myself exactly yes then we come
to any other countries yes they think
yeah I'm yes
exactly yes
exactly yeah yeah so you share our pain
because we go through the same things
we're doing all we do is we're suffering
at the hands of these people who've
hijacked our religion like for you guys
anyone
yeah imagine
government
s that they have and how they are
spending it it's awful you can see all
indications of a dictatorship and the
totalitarian regime in Iraq all
indications and one of the massive ones
is a single person in power for more
than 30 years
he has all the power and resources in
the country okay so you know one thing I
wanted to touch up on maybe it's
relating to this is that you know when
we talk about um Freedom so like for
example a person is free to wear the
hijab or know where to hit not to wear
the hijab just off topic of it um when
we talk about Freedom what do you
exactly mean because like I don't
believe personally in this concept that
you choose not to wear the hijab I don't
believe this exists like I don't I don't
I repeat again I believe that you don't
choose not to wear the hijab you are
forced not to wear the hijab
you're absolutely right because maybe
100 years later women are gonna shave
either higher because it's more
efficient
it can be anything I absolutely agree I
am not wearing the job at the moment yes
because of all the things that happened
in my life okay I understand and I'm
sorry that happened and whoever did this
I genuinely on their behalf to make you
feel now I'll be honest with you look
sometimes as Muslims the prophet peace
be upon him said I came for nothing but
to perfect good character meaning when
you look at the definition of good
characters good good and so for example
good character starts with Allah God
Almighty because some people say this
tree is good we say that's having bad
characters
because I've been enforced I'm 41 years
yeah one thing that people get wrong is
that if in a good intention even in a
Brotherhood intention they come and tell
me yes one day I'm gonna say okay
no maybe not no no it's not exactly even
with the good intentions yes do not
repeat the same message yes exactly yes
yeah so what I'm saying
yeah because I believe that people they
are most people that they look for
religion they want to have a religion of
course everybody
a purpose yes
they're fine so I'm I don't have
problems people having really yeah no I
know I know I know I know this one can
be one of those yes yes
even by being kind but repeating and
repeating that's not going to work okay
good so so what I was saying I wasn't
saying that let's be kind and do the
same thing what I was saying in general
as Muslims we should have good character
period not about you but hijab are not
original I'm just saying in general as
Muslims we are this is where the um
uh what do you call those um I forgot
the name but basically we are the ones
who are at the front we we are the ones
that people judge Islam by so it's very
important for us to conduct ourselves in
the right manner but the thing what I
was just saying that for the sister as
well is that I believe truly that for
someone to say that they don't wear the
hijab and they choose not to I believe
this is not true and luckily I'm talking
off topic I'm not talking about this
issue yeah what I mean by that is for
example there are a lot of women in this
country or around the world billions of
them who wear mini skirts they get their
nose done they get their backsides on
they get their breasts done the question
is do they choose to do this I say no
they are forced to do this
you know Islam to a side Islam to the
side
no the beauty industry other women men
Society there are many there's a book
but that happens to the people that they
have a job yes yes they're not choosing
it it just happens no no like for
example for example
why is it yeah so difficult for my
Muslim Brothers to accept that people
can think differently from them no we
accept that look what I'm saying I'm not
saying that this is the hardest thing
for you guys I can't think differently
of course I'm not saying that you're
having a very difficult time to accept
them no no I accept that I don't believe
that having your nose done job is bad as
well I don't think so so if so if a
woman my sister if a woman if a woman
tries to get her nose smashed
no
oppression
everybody their choice okay is it their
choice when the industry and the beauty
industry and the the makeup industry I'm
not gonna add verified no no but sister
what I'm saying is what if my sister
does it I'm not gonna say no no no I'm
not saying I'm not no we shouldn't hit
anybody what I'm saying is
gone okay okay thank you sorry like just
in a nutshell guys like what happened
was tragic I don't want to twist like
change the story the point I was trying
to make is this perception that we are
under that woman who cover up are forced
by a woman don't cover up are not forced
and this is a big fat lie this is a big
fat lie you look at the beauty in the
street billion dollar industry yeah now
just because somebody doesn't hit you on
the head and go don't wear the hijab get
your nose done doesn't mean they are
free the point I'm trying to say is
which woman why do they wake up in the
morning and find the need to spend two
hours doing makeup why do they find the
need to wear four inch heels and it's so
uncomfortable have to take you off in
cold weather why do they find the meat
to get their buttocks their bums excuse
me their backside is done and some of
them die in the process there was a
Brazilian woman in Brazil she got her
bum done and she died she literally
sacrificed her life for that beauty so
the point I'm trying to say is this
notion that Muslim women are oppressed
and the Western women over Iranian or
whoever it may be we choose to take you
off no you don't you are told to in a
different way and you think oh it's I
choose no you don't why'd you go like by
the way anyone can dress up how they
want to dress up in this country the
point I'm trying to make is this when I
well we shouldn't actually anybody none
of us should see this but you know it
pops up in front of you in the winter a
woman wearing a miniscule your finger to
yourself did she really choose to does
she wake up and say it's freezing cold
and I'm gonna wear mini skirt today no
she does not she's like I look I think I
look beautiful men look at me I'm I'm in
competition with other women and the
beauty industry and all of this and I am
willing to go and wear a minister that
is oppression now the same could be said
about our sisters do they wear the hijab
because they want to no they do because
they have to do I wake up a Fajr because
I want to well yeah but I do because I
have to it's not something I enjoy in
the context where I'm like it's hard
waking up for Fajr it's hard but I do it
because
um I'm told to now you're gonna say well
what's the difference you are told to
they are told to the difference is this
I choose to follow the one that created
me and it deserves My Worship and it
deserves me to obey him however the
creation the beauty industry the men and
the opposite gender and all these
industries they do not deserve me to
listen to them that is the difference
and that's the point I just wanted to
make and obviously it's sad what
happened to the sister who passed away
and this is not from Islam nowhere in
Islams that tell you to execute or kill
somebody because they do not wear their
hijab there is no
um capital punishment for this yeah
there is there isn't let's be real you
should call My Religion you know there
is capital punishment for a person yeah
and I will see this and I've got no
problem with it yeah and then in a
legitimate Islamic country but when
women come to me and make it out as if
they choose now she said I don't see any
problem with getting my nose done can
you imagine going under operation when
you get a nose down your eyes start
going you know after operation your eyes
are this big yeah it can be confusions
complications yeah you're telling me you
are willingly to go there and get your
nose done no you're not I have family
members I know I don't want to get into
detail
I go
she done it okay why did you do it oh
I've done it because it looked good on
her okay so why did you do it okay
come on man don't don't come to me with
this I'm so sorry Islam that is
establishing a Masjid and a community
center if you donate to build this
Masjid Allah is trying to build a house
for you in Jannah with bricks of gold
and silver every person who prays in
this Masjid every child that memorized
the Quran you will inshallah share in
that reward donate it now guys and do
not delay